on this episode I deliver my best
performance in a long time
[Music]
hi
this is
Carrie be everyone in this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 2 32 on
the ask gary vee show ah 231 hasn't been
posted yet right what time you guys
posted it like right after I film this
livestream so I know we've been a little
bit of hiiis just clear the air for
everybody daily me has not replaced
askgaryvee I'm just traveling a whole
lot and so you know we've been pretty
sporadic which shows which is
unfortunate but we're here and we're you
know we did one Friday which you're
about to see we're Facebook liveing so
I'm giving more context for them you've
already seen 231 so 232 Elliot you're
here and I think we should get ready to
show obviously right so we're airing
this so this is going to air tomorrow
let's do this tomorrow early um so you
know what I haven't I bought I heard
from somebody that I only made one Jets
prediction this year and it was the game
they won which makes me want to predict
but I feel like they're gonna lose
tonight though there's a little fun fact
AJ and I did not watch the Buffalo game
together and I was supposed to get an
Arizona for this game but I have so many
fires here at vaynermedia I couldn't
justify it so I didn't go so weirdly if
the Jets win today um I'm not sure if I
should watch with AJ anymore this year
cuz my people it actually works best so
anyway my prediction is the Cardinals
are gonna score some serious points
tonight it's gonna show bro
first question from shoo-bop Lydia yo
hey Gary this is Shubham from male jet I
have a question for you today is how
important were your selling skills as an
entrepreneur and what are the different
things that make you improved as a
salesman thank you very much for
answering love your show CEO shoe thank
you so much for loving the show I love
you back I think my salesmanship was the
first raw talent that I understood in my
life it has been the bedrock of my
existence the unbelievable reason that
vaynermedia is what it is today has a
lot to do with salesmanship it is
massively important when
you actually it's really funny when you
actually sell something having sales
skills is extremely important so many of
you are going to fail in your business
because you underestimate salesmanship
as a core tenet when you're trying to
sell something many of you make the
nicest thing the coolest thing it's why
artists starve because they can't sell
like selling is real I think it's been
an enormous part and I think the thing
that's made me better through my
career's experience you know like
experiences a real thing like us
youngsters we want to think it's not and
I really knew it's funny I put us
youngsters because I think of you as a
great youngster at 22 23 I thought I was
it right like like I guess I look at it
as like basketball players because I
dunk I know you love it like they become
better shooters as they like as they
become craftier they become more
experienced than the guys that are
all-time you'll notice their game
evolves you know through their careers
because they can't rely just on their
athletics anymore they've got to become
crafty they've got to be able to shoot I
mean I would say LeBron LeBron to me
could have easily been the best all-time
player he never got his jump shot
developed the way that Jordan and Kobe
did he's a different type of player but
if his jump shot was unstoppable right
now forget it and his three-point range
has gone down in his career and set up
up and up by the way I'm the biggest
LeBron guy of them all but to me a
magical Brunt like Andy I shall you
react to this I don't know if you got
something to say about this it hasn't
improved this 3-point percentage was
down last year it improved from early on
yet was down last year like and I think
it's gonna continue to go like it hasn't
improved and improved from like the
beginning but like I mean he's such a
complete you look stuff to analyte you
get to that point it's tough to analyze
LeBron because he's such a all-around
player he doesn't need to score but
anyway nonetheless the bottom line is
the 22-year old me would be disappointed
right now if he saw the 40 year old me
in salesmanship because he would
realized huh picked up some [ __ ] along
the way that I didn't have just from my
natural skills so the answer is
unbelievably and if you're why
right now and you were building a
business and you are not a natural-born
salesperson or a great at it and you are
self-aware enough to know that you need
to either get a family member okay these
guys like really in your inner circle
that are going to be there long term and
allow them to or even bring in a partner
it is that important and if you're a
good salesperson never allow yourself to
not continue to learn try different
tactics do different things
experience has made me better this shows
going good give me some love for that
pretty impressed right yeah and I'm
telling you if his shooting percentage
has gone up from 13 14 and 15 he'd be
unstoppable right now like if you
couldn't like guard him like everybody's
staying back
imagine if defenders had to go up just 6
to 18 inches on the Brawn because he was
shooting crazy him anyways let's do this
next question Tyler a third Tyler hey
Jerry what's up this is Tyler I work at
lux I know you invested in them I hope
it's going well for you my question for
you is I turned 21 in exactly a month on
October 29th
what wines do you recommend for a
beginning wine drinker thank you so much
well Tyler semi er dress Gary at
vaynermedia I'm going to send you
something on on me I'm a big fan of New
Zealand Sauvignon Blancs German
Rieslings that are have a hint of
sweetness mainly dry but a hint of
sweetness and Beaujolais and Grenache
based red wines that are a little bit
more palpable not as tannic a little
more fruit a little lighter on the red
wine side so I will uh as a wreck you
know what guys let's do this this will
be fun in Facebook and YouTube
let's put a link to four starter wines
for all the 21 year olds I'll link them
from Wine Library make sure I do that
because we'll forget after this and we
have a bad track but actually Stefan
stuck to that I think Tyler will come
through so I'll put four little links in
Facebook and and YouTube for all of you
in those categories I just mentioned or
I'll actually look through wine
library's inventory right now and see if
anything else stands out yeah
next question is from Jessica Jessica
hey Gary what's up is jessica louise lee
here I was at the our concern event here
in Toronto I stood up to ask you but we
didn't get to it after Geo and Nick
chased you at the stage but it's all
good I would love to know what how you
would describe joy and what brings you
joy what brings Gary joy thank you so
much for pursuing all the values that
you get on stage it was amazing thanks
for the book I've been enjoying it every
single day starting off my day that way
so thank you thank you thank you
oh come on Oklahoma Jess you know what
I'm decided I'm going to share something
for a lot of you that watched for a long
time this is gonna be a cool moment I
think if you think it's cool um truth is
I talked a lot about the strategy of
5149 giving a little bit more for the
leverage of it the truth is it's my most
natural joyous state you know I've I've
molded it and I have I that's not there
because I'm not manipulated in molding
it I'm trying to be cynical here I've
experienced the benefits of it from a
business standpoint but I didn't think
that way when I was eight years old when
I was ten years old and on my tenth
birthday when my grandma took me to Toys
R Us I decided to buy my sister a
Cabbage Patch doll because I knew she
would be more excited about me doing
that than me buying anything at Toys R
Us I have always been this person I like
making people feel good
because it makes me feel good I'm being
selfish by providing others value
because it brings me my biggest joy and
so and I'm not saying and the reason
I've never talked about it is what I
just said is so douchey it's like you
know what it is it's like when you
interview somebody you're like what's
your weakness and they're like I work
too hard it's like such a douchey answer
it's a non answer it's a compliment
saying your greatest joy is giving to
others in the way that makes you feel is
a douchey thing to say so here I am
I've been deep in the garyvee world
since 2009 please not necessarily
because it's
win-win it isn't win-win but it's like
the reason I've never really gone there
and I don't even know why this question
made me feel like I've now went there it
is um yeah I mean of course it's a
win-win but I'm I'm always conscious of
everybody watching so for example this
weekend I don't know if any of you guys
saw go on my Facebook feed if you did it
if you're watching on YouTube I posted a
video of me garage selling this Saturday
and I showed some stuff it was a really
fun day because I will and we've already
talked about that this Saturday get
ready for it but I I Vic I don't show my
kids so I wasn't really able to film all
of it there were people who thought I
staged it did you see this there were
people who said oh you're right you
can't [ __ ] a bullshitter I'm like
this [ __ ] I mean if you can't you're
[ __ ] visible [ __ ] or I'm gonna [ __ ]
it's the cynicism is so wild so wild
like do you really think I with
everything I've got going on in my life
and the leverage and all the good stuff
that my new plan my new plan was not
this Saturday I'm gonna trick people I'm
gonna go to some store and buy things
and make like what is a matter with
people then somebody else is like what
is this all leading to a ten thousand
dollar how to make money on ebay course
I'm like yet [ __ ] a ten thousand
dollar to make money on ebay course no
[ __ ] it's for me to spend some time
with my kids and the show people that
this is the world I came from as a kid
it's still tangible there's a shitload
of you that could actually really
benefit from three hundred dollars a
week more and money learn something
including the thrill of the hunt and how
to how to educate yourself to know the
value of things how did you copy and
salesmanship an eBay environment which
is the most ultimate competitive
environment and how to hustle because
while all of you were sleeping Saturday
morning I was out going through [ __ ]
trash that's what I was doing so anyway
where was I going to come out and say my
great joy is to give other people joy
because it makes me feel so [ __ ] good
it's going to be met with such obnoxious
amounts of cynicism that I don't wanna
waste the time
on it but it's the answer to that
question that's the truth
and and by the way I got this is where
Locke comes in I know a lot of you say I
hate luck let me tell you what luck is
luck is that you were built in a way
where that is genuinely the way you feel
because then you actually do it because
you love it and then enormous ly awesome
[ __ ] happens to you so how do you think
I work so hard cuz I'm filled with
gratitude that I was built that way cuz
that gift that [ __ ] gift is the
[ __ ] thing
next crime Blair well you know when you
come off these big vacations you yes ya
got five are you coming up I'm excited
this is by the way I wanted to put this
right by the way let me get right to it
I want to get this Ryan question and I
don't really know Ryan but a lot of my
friends know Ryan I know he's got this
book out I've seen some of the stuff
we've been I think we had dinner once at
a bit but I'm excited to like give him
this first so I have no idea what he's
gonna say but I wanted him to do the
question because I wanted you know what
I'm hearing is this book is pretty good
from a lot of people I trust so I
haven't had it yet who reddit or what
have you I would never read it cuz I
don't read books but hearing nice things
I want to give Ryan some exposure so I
should disclose it you're Gary prepping
for our conversation here today as you
know I got my book coming out rock
bottom to Rockstar and so I figured I'd
ask you questions around this framework
what what did you do to get through your
personal rock bottom moments to become
the rock star that you are
I'll stop right there sorry so let's
start with what Brian what uh you know
my rock bottom moment happened super
early it was by being an immigrant and
getting teased for not speaking English
you know I don't talk a lot about
drinking the pee out of the Pepsi can in
Dover New Jersey which I never
referenced cuz I lived there for a year
before I moved to Edison maybe even
subconsciously because of that that was
sucky but that was five I mean we all
got picked on um I just think my whole
childhood in some weird way it was
awesome which is why everything is
awesome but man I don't know if anybody
could have disliked school more than me
I think we all hated school and homework
but I failed and oh by the way Tyler
tonight when you get the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles things out of my car
tonight when you get the TMT out of my
car my report cards in there it's time
to take the pictures yeah um you know
I struggled I was happy I wasn't like I
was a very happy kid but I hated school
like on a different planet and I think
all of you know me like look what's
happened in my life like I really hated
it so my rock bottom moment was really
my school career
keep going whoo-hoo did I get help from
her what what's he gonna say who who did
you surround yourself work with who was
it was it yorky next was it so stop
right there good book my mom and dad
that's who am i who are my mom was
building my self-esteem about me oh I'll
never forget I open the door for a woman
in McDonald's when I was like nine my
mom and you don't wanna hang he got real
work I got it real work I'm excited my
mom you know made that out to be the
greatest thing that a human had ever
done she accentuated she blew up she
over emphasized great things which made
me a good person and my dad my dad you
know tuck and still unbelievable hard
work ethic my mom did as well word is
bond you know provided for our family
came here with zero I look up to him so
much for that struggle so my my what was
the struggles early on in my childhood
my who was my parents who are showing me
through their actions not only their
words what to do who was it that you
work with to get through these tough
times because I know nobody can do it
alone
why why did you do it did you do it
because you love somebody and you want
to show them that you were better than
that I know you got a lot of grit but my
why back then was I had a chip on my
shoulder I was getting D's and F's
you'll see that soon with my report card
content this week was getting these nets
and the world was telling me I was a
loser
my teachers were telling me a loser my
friend's parents weren't singing to my
face that I was a loser but I could see
in their eye that I didn't think I'd be
successful because the game I played on
like today's game in the 80s early 90s
was school was the way out going to
Harvard was the great accomplishment not
building Facebook or Instagram or being
a successful entrepreneur was a
different landscape and so you know the
Y was to [ __ ] stick to everybody like
I used to sit there as a 13 14 15 16
year old and look at my class of my
teachers I'm like I'm gonna show you
I'm gonna show all of you you think I
suck I'm gonna be the biggest best
person on earth you feel like you're why
has changed of course your career no
because that you know chip never goes
away it's why I'm willing to put in the
work it's why and I want to give you
know it's funny
we're getting to a theme I want to give
Saturday was a selfish thing spend time
with my kids on something I care about
but I've done that I didn't film before
and had to be very careful because I
don't want to show them like I did that
because I'm gonna show people I want to
I want to help them I inspire people
people got pumped over the weekend like
people wouldn't like people went out
Sunday morning and made money I got like
real emails in my inbox like Sunday
morning I got pumped I bought this
printer for 30 I just sold it for 90 I
need 60 bucks 54 after fees I know dicks
let's go you carrying that comes from
somewhere so why did you do it did you
have a deeper purpose did you not want
to let yourself daily let someone else
down where did you have a bigger cause
in mind I did it and then how what did
you do specifically what steps did you
do when you are at your lowest moments
yeah but snow yeah during that point
what did i do is I did what I preached
to all of you which is I put in the work
I gave up all my weekends and holidays
in high school because I knew I had to
pay that price because I wasn't gonna do
the I'm gonna go to school meet some
good kids at Stanford and brown Ivy
League school make some relationships
and that's going to be my springboard I
was going to start with no relationships
and in the gutter and I was gonna have
to prove it and I would have to show up
and mean everybody like I did in my 30s
but in my teens and 20s I was gonna have
to work and so what I did was to the
extreme of anybody I've met that had
options some people lose their father
mother welfare but anybody who had some
options I punted every leisure activity
in my life nothing no weekends no
vacations zero nothing nothing like
we're making jokes about the seven days
I didn't take a single and by the way
yeah but like but it's my truth I didn't
take a single vacation day never and I'm
sure you worked on your siteís I just
love you and I don't wanna razz you like
none zerah zerah
zero all my high school friends gone
because I wasn't around all my college
friends post-college gone I'd see them a
little bit I love those guys but God
girlfriends nothing all in so what did I
do I've worked I worked to such an
extreme level that when I push you on
work
I don't even ask you to do 50% of what I
did and I guarantee you'll [ __ ] win
last question from Blake it's gonna be a
big time episode it's a really good life
I'm like fired I don't never fire on my
own self
hey Gary and Harry's crew good evening
from Lincoln Nebraska I'm Blake Bowlin
actually enjoying a Malbec currently
pretty good one from Argentina but I was
thinking about a question for the
askgaryvee show
specifically one pertaining to the
askgaryvee book gary in the book you
talk about how you believe our brains
and what they're capable of are vastly
underestimated and that science has yet
to prove really what they're truly
capable of you also mention as an
example that a few years ago you told
your brain you didn't want to get sick
anymore
then you tribute the fact that you
haven't gotten sick too when you told
your brain that you didn't want to get
sick anymore
now I recently stumbled upon the law of
attraction I'd heard of it before but I
really dug in depth in a audio book if
you're familiar with it and for those of
you who aren't familiar with it the law
of attraction basically states whatever
you focus on will manifest itself so if
you focus on the things you want to
accomplish and you believe you can
accomplish them they will manifest
themselves over time whereas if you
focus on the things you don't want those
things will also manifest themselves so
the point is to focus on things you do
want so Gary I'm wondering about the
relationship between your beliefs in the
law of attraction and if you could
explain how we in vaynernation can
leverage those concepts to better live
our lives both personally and in our
businesses so Gary looking forward to
your response here and thank you so much
for taking my question Godspeed blank
it's a really interesting question yes I
believe in some of that stuff and I
don't know how much the law of
attraction is different than the secret
sounds very similar these books sell
like crazy because boy does it sound
super fun right now if you're sitting on
facebook live or watching episode 2 3
- is that we're on you know like then
you're like wait a minute if I just say
I want a yacht or if I just say I want
to be a pop singer or I just want to say
I'm going to be an influencer I don't
know what either of those two books say
but let me give you what I've done
go ahead please you know the secret is
basically based off of the law of
attraction okay a lot of attraction is
the like it's like it's like the
religion
sort of say and the secret is a book
which is basically how players on it
it's very hot straight from God of
Attraction so listen I believe in it ,
all of your actions have to then map to
it so like it's it's clouds and dirt
that's my version of it I don't know if
anybody talks about the dirt I do I do I
know only you know cynical newbies are
like what's he gonna sell me on nothing
I'm gonna sell you on the following hard
work and don't buy my hard work course
because there isn't one there's no hard
work sessions there's no hard work ebook
this is hard work like so my answer to
this is I believe in it but then you
have to make your actions map it I want
to buy the New York Jets I think about
it I want it I start building
vaynermedia there's an opportunity to
sell my company sell a piece of my
company to thousands of entities all of
them pass I then sell it for less to one
entity an owner on a bad NFL team that's
called putting your money where your
mouth is I didn't do that by acts I knew
what kind of life I had I could have
dated and married a bunch of different
people but when I found what I needed
for what I really knew I wanted I went
in that direction right like I talked
about HR driven culture and this and
that and some people be like guy you got
a bad review on Glassdoor or four seven
yes that's fine but come here watch what
I do every day
you guys know my calendar you see what I
do you know what's on the back end of
this like so my belief in the law
traction is Blake believe in it believe
in it but then you have to execute
against your belief if you want to be an
eSports celebrity shouldn't you spend
every one of your minutes selling [ __ ]
on eBay buying a ticket and then going
to the eSports con not like oh I can't
go to the eSports con work
work by the way on that note we got to
pick up the musically you're just you're
a killer on it I want it I'm so into it
that work work work reward is so fun
good setting I was saying right now what
that's like that tone work like it's
work like there's gonna be nothing else
like yes work smart I can hear the
cynicism already I can read the comment
from Sally right now but you gotta work
stock no [ __ ]
Sally leaving Rick alone for a minute
you know no [ __ ] yes it's better to have
a better strategy and to work smarter
but here's the punchline nothing happens
without it and I mean a lot of it and
the more you want the more work you
gotta put in the bigger your ambition
the more you got to punch that clock and
you got to give up [ __ ] fun and leisure
and laziness and rest and all of it so
my belief is it's real I live it but my
actions map to it it's like intent I
talk a lot about intent
some of the people internally razz me
about it they're like yeah cool but a
tent without you're backing up the
actions is wack and I'm like I respect
that
but it starts with intent so I believe
it probably starts with visualizing what
you want there the Law of Attraction are
saying you're putting in the universe
fine fine I believe in that I live it
the problem is I disproportionally out
execute everybody else I know that talks
about it and then does nothing about it
you know any of you tweeted me that
you're gonna buy the calves or the
Dolphins or the Rams people tweet me all
day long that they're buying another
sports team then I go look at what
they're doing I'm weird just let's
establish something I'm very weird I'm
so broken in the way that I'm so utterly
competitive that I'm like I live for it
you know I live for competition and so
when somebody tweets me that they're
gonna buy the Rams first my waist seven
my minutes auditing their lives
let me tell all of you something right
now I haven't seen the person that's
buying the Rams before I buy the Jets
people like to talk show me because
that's the best part because when you
live on execution all those things you
have where people say you're staging
garage sales or you're not going to do
this or you're not going to do that you
know the best part is 2023 2023
because then you get to say now lot and
2047 that's more fun look I'll let you
guys all debate and pontificate and I'm
going to do it too we're all talking I
just want to re-watch these videos and
comments
let's go read everybody's comments that
I could never build vaynermedia let's go
read everybody's comments that Yui
mcafee was a farce let's go read all
those comments that I'm a flash in a pan
let's read them all let's [ __ ] read
them question of the day what gets you
going what motivates you you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them and
executing on them for [ __ ] ever
[Music]